when it comes to the holidays people are
worried about having enough money to pay
for gifts and how much more things will
cost in December compared to what they
cost now what should you buy now our
consumer savings expert weighs in
a recent poll shows 55 percent of
Shoppers plan to start shopping for
Christmas by the end of this month
retailers are responding by offering
sales with the goal to get you to spend
more than you really want consumer
savings expert Andrea warrock says shop
strategically so you don't overspend and
get into debt just because something is
on sale doesn't mean you should buy it
and if you do start shopping early in
October it's kind of easy to lose track
of what you bought or how much you spent
if you do start early you can keep track
of your budget gifts and spending with
an app like Santa's bag it lets you set
a budget for different people share with
friends and family warrock says some of
the best things to buy early would be
hot holiday toys anything that you know
that kids are going crazy for maybe
those LOL surprise dolls
um Barbie Dream House Star Wars special
edition toys I mean there are so many
things out there that are popular the
Nintendo switch the PS5 those things
that are likely to sell out if it's on
sale now there's no no reason to wait
buy it because chances are inventory
could drop later and chances are it
won't be a better price over Black
Friday when it comes to things like
holiday Decor you'll find better deals
in December so hold off winter apparel
tends to be cheaper right before
Christmas and right after if you want to
buy it as a gift wait for the last two
weeks leading up to the holiday if it's
not a gift and you can wait it out right
after when it comes to electronics like
mobile phones big screen TVs Warwick
says wait as they tend to be best priced
during Black Friday deals and or Cyber
Monday
and new this year a lot of retailers are
offering extra wiggle room in their
price adjustment policies like Target
who says if you buy anything between
October 6th and December 24th that then
goes on sale they'll offer a price
adjustment